only 18 days since everything closed
down it's 39 days since the first Kovac
case in New York feels like a lifetime
it's 80 days since we had the first
Kovac case in the United States 80 days
been an intense life-changing 80 days
but that's what it has been when we
started this situation that we are still
in the midst of before people get
complacent the end of March the White
House Task Force coronavirus Task Force
were still talking about one point five
to two point two million deaths okay
their best case scenario with quote
unquote mitigation efforts was 100 to
240 thousand deaths in the United States
which is breathtaking
for New York there were a number of
models that were put out that we are
following the the most frightening was
Columbia University that said we could
have 136 thousand people in New York
City
only who would be hospitalized not
infected
we had the McKinsey model which
suggested a hundred and ten thousand
people could be hospitalized statewide
we had a second scenario from McKinsey
which is 55,000 people hospitalized and
then the Gates Foundation thank you very
much funded the IME study which said a
high point of 73,000 statewide any of
these scenarios are devastating for New
York because remember we only have a
53,000 bed capacity system statewide
36,000 beds in New York City so any of
these scenarios
problematic luckily the current trend if
it continues and if we continue the
flattening of the curve we're at about
18,000 people hospitalized right now
we've increased the capacity of the
system dramatically
we have moved pieces around the state
like never before our health care system
has done a phenomenal job in doing an
insurmountable task our federal partners
the Army Corps of Engineers they have
just really all done a great great job
and our theory and I believe my job as
governor prepare for the worst hope for
the best but prepare for the worst
now we're at about 90,000 bed capacity
in our overall system today with
everything we've done even the 90,000
beds as you see doesn't compare with the
most problematic scenarios 90,000 beds
we can handle the McKenzie moderate
scenario we don't make the McKenzie
severe scenario at 110,000 I believe
that 90,000 we have a plan to get to 110
converting dormitories etc etc but it
would be a massive undertaking and a
massive scramble we do make the gates
funded projection model the Columbia
University model we can never that would
just be a nightmare that is the one that
keeps me up at nights because you
couldn't get anywhere near that
projection but all of the statisticians
also said look we don't know how
effective you can be at closing things
down and social distancing because we've
never done it before but they all said
that's the chance to so-called flatten
the curve if you actually got people to
comply with all these measures and we
have never seen it done before in this
country and we don't know if you can do
it
so that is the big if in the equation
and that remains the big if in the
equation you can flatten the curve we
are flattening the curve by what we're
doing and we're flattening the curve so
far we should all be concerned
especially in New Yorkers well we're
flattening the curve that's good news it
is good news well now I can relax no you
can't relax the flattening of the curve
last night happened because of what we
did yesterday and the day before in the
day before that this is all a direct
consequence to our actions if we stop
acting the way we're acting you will see
those numbers go up and I show the
projection models because we can't
handle the worst-case scenarios we can't
even handle the moderate case scenarios
with all we've done so it is essential
that we keep that curve flattened
because we don't have an option of
handling the curve if it goes higher the
additional good news is the
hospitalization rate does suggest that
it's coming down and we are flattening
the curve we had 200 net increase in
hospitalizations which you can see is
the lowest number we've had since this
nightmare started actually change in ICU
admissions is the lowest number we've
had since March 19th or so so all of
this data suggests that we are
flattening the curve so far and the
numbers are coming down so far a number
of intubations is down three-day average
on intubations is down so so far our
efforts are working they're working
better than anyone projected they would
work that's because people are complying
with them you know there are always two
questions can you enact these policies
and then can you enact the policies in a
way that people
you know we we can enact a policy and
people thumbed their nose to it and
continue doing what they're doing so
there has to be a social acceptance and
adherence to the policy and new yorkers
are doing that they're acting
responsibly and diligently and we are
saving lives by what people are doing
today our expression has been New York
tough because every day is tough on many
many levels I get it
but every day that we are New York tough
we are actually saving lives and don't
underestimate this virus I think that is
a mistake we made from day one we as the
collective we we as the global community
this virus is very very good at what it
does we lost more lives yesterday and we
have to date we understand and all the
experts have said dr. Fauci said from
day one to me you will see the deaths
increasing after the hospitalizations
because the deaths increase the longer a
person is in the hospital the longer
longer a person is on the ventilator I
understand the scientific concept I
understand the data but you're talking
about 799 lives the highest number ever
it's gotten to the point frankly that
we're going to going to bring in
additional funeral directors to deal
with the number of people who have
passed if you ever told me that as
governor I would have to take these
actions
I couldn't even contemplate where we are
now and to put all of this in
perspective I lived through 9/11 9/11
was supposed to be the darkest day in
New York for a generation we've done
everything we can since 9/11
make sure 9/11 didn't happen again we
lose twenty-seven hundred and fifty
three lives on 9/11 we've lost over
seven thousand lives to this crisis that
is so shocking and painful and
breathtaking I can't I don't even have
the words for it
9/11 was so devastating so tragic and
then in many ways we lose so many more
New Yorkers to this this silent killer
there was no explosion but it was a
silent explosion that just ripples
through society with the same randomness
the same evil that we saw on 9/11 what
do we do we move forward and we do the
work that we need to do we're going to
start an effort called New York loves
which is gonna be a coordination of all
the charities and not-for-profits and
foundations and people who want to help
there's been a tremendous outpouring of
support from organized not-for-profits
etc but also people just wanted to
donate people just wanting to help the
best effort is if we can coordinate all
those resources to make sure there's not
duplication and we're actually
addressing the right need so the State
Department of State Rosanna Rosario
Secretary of State and Fran Barrett who
coordinates not-for-profits we will
coordinate all the people who want to
donate and help and we'll work with the
local governments that need help also
let's learn the lessons of what we're
going through now because we haven't
finished going through it let's learn
how and why this virus kills especially
why we have higher fatality rates among
african-americans and Latinos and what
we do about it let's understand it but
let's also address it we're going to be
doing more testing in african-american
and Latino communities with more data
we're going to open new testing sites
primarily in african-american Latino
communities with SUNY Albany Department
of Health north well collect the test
results but also collect the information
that we need to come up with policies to
fix this where do people live where do
people work what's the socioeconomic
status where do they socialize what are
their previous health conditions why do
we have these higher rates and what do
we do about it and let's do that now
rapid testing and testing is going to be
the bridge to the new economy and
getting to work and restarting right
we're not going to go from red to green
we're going to go from red to yellow
yellow is let the people who can go back
to work start going back to work well
how do you know who can go back to work
test them you have rapid testing
capacity we have to bring it to scale we
have to bring it to scale quickly and
that's something that this state is
working on as well as the federal
government let's also find the treatment
for this disease convalescent plasma
which is plasma from people who were
infected that can be then used to treat
people who get infected
we need that plasma from people who were
infected we're starting a blood drive
and asking those who have recovered from
the virus to contact us and to donate
blood so we can develop the convalescent
plasma treatment and there's a website
on the screen that they can go to to
help we also have to be prepared and
stay prepared we have to have the
supplies we have to know have the right
laws we have to have the right
procedures because remember the 1918
Spanish flu came in three waves we're on
the first wave everybody is assuming
well once we get through this we're done
I wouldn't be so quick to assume that
this virus has been ahead of us from day
one we've underestimated the enemy and
is always dangerous my friends and we
should not do that again it's an article
in the LA Times that says the
communities that have dealt with this
before
like Wuhan Singapore are now seeing a
second wave of infection there is a
theory that this virus can mutate and
change and come back so this is not
we're in a battle right but this is
about a war and we're only on one battle
here even once we get through this
battle we have to stay prepared for what
could come down the road and we also
have to start to repair the immense
damage before you start talking about
restarting the economy you're going to
have to address the damage that is done
to society today which is intense the
economic dev damage people who are now
living in poverty I mean people have
been without a check without a job for
weeks and most people in this state live
paycheck to paycheck and all of a sudden
the paycheck stop stops we're doing
everything we can on the unemployment
benefits and increasing the unemployment
benefits but you have families that are
in true economic hardship and are
impoverished because of this situation
what we do with the housing market our
health care system we have pushed to the
max we have pushed people to the max we
have pushed facilities to the max we
have beds in lobbies in conference rooms
in hallways I mean we did what we had to
do to be ready but we have done a lot of
damage in the midst that has to be
undone so that's something that we're
working on immediately and we need the
federal government to be responsible and
we need the federal government to pass
legislation that helps we have to
stabilize state and local governments
across this country New York State has
had the highest number of cases by far
and away
our costs have been the highest in the
country the passed legislation that was
enacted we were told would bring six
billion dollars to health care when we
did our state budget a couple of weeks
ago we believed what they said and we
thought we were looking at six billion
dollars in health care funding turns out
when we actually read the language it
was about 1.3 billion dollars to the
state of New York which is much
different than five or six billion
dollars and the funding disqualified one
third of New York's Medicaid recipients
which nobody said you know and to our
federal representatives I spoke to
Senator Schumer I spoke to Senator
Gillibrand this is no time for politics
this is a time to enact the legislation
that actually addresses the need and I
was in Washington for eight years I get
how the political process works in
Washington not here and not now my
friends we also have a significant
mental health issue that comes with what
we've done the isolation the
disorientation it's a growing problem we
have a growing problem with a number of
domestic violence cases if you need help
during this highly stressful period and
I suspect more people need help then
acknowledge that they need help we have
a support hotline we have thousands of
people who volunteer to help and people
should reach out and ask for it we have
to stay ahead of this virus we're
watching Rockland Nassau and Suffolk the
numbers have come down in New York City
but you look at the concentric circles
around New York City the natural spread
the natural concentric circles are
towards the suburban communities was
just a Rockland Nassau Suffolk
Westchester we've had problems already
one of the first hotspots in the nation
was
Rochelle in Westchester now we're seeing
numbers creep up in Rockland Nassau and
Suffolk the numbers are creeping up so
we're watching those areas next to be
sent additional equipment last night and
the overall point is look you stay at
home and you save a life period stay at
home and you save a life and I know New
Yorkers I'm born and bred the instinct
is well this is good news now I can
relax because by the way I've been dying
to relax
and get out of the house and end this
Groundhog Day reality yeah you're not
out of the woods and now is not the time
to misunderstand what's happening we
have done great things and we have saved
lives because we have followed these
policies the moment you stop following
the policies you will go right back and
see that that number shoot through the
roof and we are not prepared to handle
the highest numbers in those projection
models whatever we do you can't take a
50,000 bed system and get it to 136
thousand beds it's an impossibility and
I'm a person who never says no and
believes New York can do anything if we
try I'm telling you we have to keep that
curve flat today we can say that we have
lost many of our brothers and sisters
but we haven't lost anyone because they
didn't get the right and best health
care that they could the way I sleep at
night is I believe that we didn't lose
anyone that we could have saved and that
is the only solace when I look at these
numbers and look at this pain that's
been created
that has to be true and that has to
continue and that is a function of what
each and every one of us does so New
York tough yes
we're tough the tough means we're smart
with disciplined we're unified and we're
loving and if you don't want to stay
home for yourself stay home for someone
you love right that's what the
stay-at-home campaign is all about you
want to have reckless disregard for your
life it's not about your life it's about
the health care worker who will have to
treat you in the emergency room it's
about the vulnerable person who you
infect who you could kill by your
actions sometimes it's not about you
right it's not about me it's about we
and that's where we are questions no I
don't think we have we're not planning
nursing homes for Kovac patients
governor millions of people are applying
for unemployment nationwide and hundreds
of thousands here in New York we've
gotten consistent reports that they
can't get through to operators at the
New York State Department of Labor this
has been going on for weeks
what sort of assurances can you offer
residents that they can get these
benefits particularly in times of
economic hardship yeah look the Technol
technology at the Department of Labor
the system just crashed because of the
volume right it's one of those
unanticipated consequences of a
situation like this and again
Jesse nobody's been here before we'll
learn for the next time but yeah you
have a government shuts down the private
sector economy you have millions of our
out of work the next shooter drop is
going to be millions of people calling
for for unemployment benefits crashing
the system that handles the unemployment
benefits because you've had a
hundredfold increase which is what has
happened we have 1,000 people who are
now working on just personnel for that
incoming system think about that 1,000
people who are working on processing
applications for unemployment benefits
that was like the number we used to get
of applicants now we have 1,000 people
processing applications we're working
with Google to come up with an online
mechanism that bypasses any phone
certification the phone certification
was important because you want to make
sure that people who are applying are
also qualified so we're doing everything
we can
the good news is whenever you sign up
your benefits are going to be
retroactive you will not have received
the check I get that and that's causing
anxiety but it's not like you're not
going to get the same benefit because
you didn't get through on Monday and you
didn't get through until Thursday
melissa has been working on the system
everybody a little bit of context these
numbers will come out later today but
last week there were 350,000
unemployment claims in New York going
back to March 9th we're at eight hundred
and ten thousand unemployment claims so
far 600,000 of those claims have been
successfully processed so you've got
over two hundred thousand that are still
in partial status what happens is you go
online you fill out the application if
you fill out the application in full
you're done if you leave any of the
fields blank what's been happening is
they tell you call the system so you
call the system to follow up
that's what then caused the crash and
volume and then the system goes down as
the governor said we've been working
with Google today between 5:00 and 7:00
p.m. the system is going to go down to
reboot seven o'clock the new application
goes online it's streamlined there are
fewer questions and once you get to the
end of that if you successfully fill it
out it's going to say you're finished
with the application process if there's
any information that's left blank it's
going to say don't call us we will call
you within 72 hours in DOL as the
governor said now has a thousand people
on the phone lines they're going to be
reaching out directly to the people so
that people don't have to go through
this infuriating process of calling and
getting busy signal's and thereby
collapsing the system
so hopefully starting today after seven
o'clock the system will be much better
streamlined but as the governor said
it's a volume issue that we've never
experienced yeah I'll ask Rob he could
speak about the financial stress that
the state is under but look of so many
of these things we've never seen before
we have never seen the financial
devastation done to the state budget the
way it has happened here again in my
lifetime we go back to 9/11 which was
the catastrophic event this is more
devastating to the New York economy in
New York budget which is just a function
of the New York economy then 9/11 by far
but Rob do you want to speak to the
questions for Karen's question sure just
look at it in the context that we're
talking about we're looking at a revenue
shortfall of between ten to fifteen
billion dollars and those numbers are
trending more towards the middle of that
right now look at a context of where we
have 50 percent of the workforce is
staying at home just of the state
workforce as Melissa just mentioned over
800,000 new unemployment claims in the
past three weeks and we don't have
frankly don't have the money right to
make these parents everything at this
time it makes sense to take a pause the
two percent raises don't go in effect
for at least 90 days and 90 days we'll
review it once we have a better picture
of what the state's fiscal picture looks
like we've been asking the federal
government to provide assistance to the
state if you look at a lot of the labor
unions recognize the state only has a
certain amount of resources trying to
prioritize those resources right now to
fund the health care crisis and the min
between now and then let's take a break
and let's see if the federal government
is going to step up provide the state
with more resources to deal with the
revenue shortfall and then we can deal
with those commitments to your question
where does the state get to have the
authority within the pay bills for each
of these contracts when the legislature
passes them there are provisions in
there to allow for withholds of these
payments so that's what we're relying on
right now and again we will relook at it
in 90 days once we have a better
perspective follow up on that current
the look life is options right you have
a 10 to 15 billion dollar shortfall what
are you going to do about it you I can't
just sit here and say I'm efficiently
operating the state when I know we don't
have money to pay the bills that were
incurring right now the options are you
could do layoffs of state workers option
a option B you could buy some time with
freezing the raises to state workers I
choose option B rather than laying off
people which would only add to the
unemployment claims the stress the
hardship let's freeze the raises because
that's better than losing your job and
let's see if the federal government
actually does what they said they've
been going to do for the past several
weeks which is passed legislation that
understands the level of the crisis and
gets the state some funding to stabilize
our finances it's about fifty million
dollars for the
plan to you know share that once it gets
approval with New Jersey and Connecticut
to coordinate a testing protocol as part
of yeah we are doing the antibody
testing as we speak
State Department of Health has an
approved antibody test is now about
bringing it to scale it's all of these
testing protocols they all basically
exist none of them are at scale and
that's the next challenge how do you get
rapid testing 15-minute tests to scale
right we need millions of them we have
roughly your workforce of about 8
million people you want people to go
back to work how many of that was 8
million can you test on the rapid
testing how many can you test on the
antibody test to see if they were
infected how many can you treat on the
convalescent plasma protocol which were
asking for blood donations so all of
them it's a question of coming to scale
these are not government-run programs
they are basically private sector run
programs so we're reaching out and
working with private sector companies
who could bring these tests to scale in
New York whatever we do I try to do with
New Jersey and Connecticut again because
this is not a New York centric situation
this is a national situation the best I
can coordinate is by doing it regionally
with New Jersey and Connecticut and we
talked about the tri-state metropolitan
area the workforce comes in to New York
City in New Jersey Connecticut there's a
lot of sharing among those three states
so whatever we try to do we we try to do
together and we argue we are doing this
same thing same thing it's both the
governor Lamont and governor Murphy
about it yesterday
I'm not confident that any state would
have a complete count in this
environment let me just think about it
you're doing a census in the middle of
this environment you're knocking on
doors trying to make contact with people
after everything they hear is don't make
contact with a person who you don't know
so it's an extraordinarily difficult
time to be doing the census and I don't
know what we're going to get but that's
not a New York issue really that's a
national issue but I think it's highly
problematic I think if you look at the
numbers forget the second home theory
it's going to be people from Suffolk
come in to work into New York City
people from Rockland come in to work in
New York City and have been you know
it's a suburban community parts of
Rockland and Suffolk are bedroom
community so to speak for New York City
so that's going to far outweigh any
second home theory just in terms of
numbers look when we talk about
preparedness this was and I don't want
to get into a retrospective when you're
in the middle of the game right because
we're still in the middle of the game so
it's not the time to start to do a
retrospective on how the game was played
when you're in the middle of the game
let's just play together let's finish
the game and then we'll talk about what
could have been done differently or
should have been done differently but
excuse me one second the we're in the
middle of the game and the game is going
to go on for a period of time and there
may be another game right after it if
any of
rumors about second wave are true or the
the Spanish flu second third wave the
supplies the equipment is a real issue
to address now there's different ways to
do it the federal government the
president said you know federal gum is
not a shipping clerk for States one
theory is the federal government is the
supply purchaser for states that states
aren't left to their own to scale up for
a global pandemic the federal government
doesn't that's what FEMA does I come
from a strong federal government
background part of the Clinton
administration we were very active on
disasters and FEMA was a really key
player so to me that's a viable option
yes this is a federal emergency
declaration it is a war when you go to
war that's a federal effort right it's
not state-by-state that declares war
it's not state-by-state that you go out
and you buy tanks this is a global
pandemic it's a national situation
something like 98 percent of the country
is under stay home orders now the
federal government is the purchaser in
chief strategist and chief FEMA buys the
equipment distributes it to the states
that needed okay that's option a and I
think that's a viable option but people
can say well I don't want to do that
option B okay option B could
theoretically be designed we've never
done this if you're saying the states
have to be responsible for their own
stockpile and their own purchasing of
pharmaceuticals and medical equipment
for a global pandemic then the states
have to do it in a way where they're not
competing with each other I mean this
was just crazy that I'm bidding on a
machine that
Illinois is bidding on in California is
bidding on in Florida is bidding on and
we're all bidding up each other I'm
trying to buy masks at the same time
that everyone else is trying to buy
masks that is just and I'm going through
all of these efforts I have to figure
out how to do business with China where
I have no natural connection as a state
and every state has to scramble to find
business connections with China I mean
it was just it was crazy
that can't happen again if the federal
government doesn't do it then the states
as a consortium I would suggest do it
and let the states create a national
consortium of states to do the
purchasing in lieu of the federal
government and then that consortium
could work with each individual state
for an allocation for that state or a
purchasing agreement for that state I'm
part of something called the National
Governors Association which is an
association of all the governors I'm the
what's called the vice chairman now I
become the chairman but it's something
I'm going to focus on and work on I
becomes human in a few months
it's a rotating cycles if the federal
government's not going to do it then the
states have to do it and they have to
know that they have to do it and they
have to be prepared and they have to do
it together
but what happened now can't happen again
and it can't continue to happen right
yes DCJS on our state prison system and
on the local jails DCJS has provided
guidance and new procedures and we can
get that to you
prisoners or any further guidance to
stop the spread any specific I would
have to check what's know of DCJS has
done recent guidance but I can find out
what is it mayor de Blasio said that we
might see some of these restrictions
relaxed by May at some point but you
keep comparing this to 911 you say it's
taken a catastrophic hit to our state
budget also the death toll can you talk
a little bit about I'm not going to
guess when the data will say we should
change our practices it's a guess
well maybe by Easter maybe by May maybe
by June Broadway thanks June and by the
way Broadway is a very important part of
our economy I get it there's a lot of
jobs that's a big economic engine but
how can you say that how can you who who
can look forward and say this is where
we're going to be in three to four weeks
you saw the projection models by the
expert companies which frankly were all
off thus far so I'm not going to say to
anyone I
this is where I think we'll be in three
weeks or four weeks or five weeks I have
no idea I don't know if that curve goes
up I don't know if that curve goes down
it depends on what we do and we'll know
when we get there you know we look at
the data every day and every decision we
make is in some ways very simple as
dramatic as they are they're all data
driven by experts this is you look at
the numbers and the numbers and the data
should drive the policy it's not what
you politically would like it's not what
you think it's not what you hope you
know I have my own hopes my own but make
the decision on the data and I'm not
going to tell you what the data I think
the data says in five weeks because I
have no idea and I've spoken to the
smartest people on the planet for the
past month about this and I'm telling
you the smartest person will start by
saying I don't
no and that's to me the sign of wisdom
in all of this
well this economy has been shut down
tighter remember 9/11 in retrospect 9/11
was about was catastrophic emotionally
and physically and culturally and it it
it gave us a sense of vulnerability that
we never had before but on the pure
numbers for the economy this has been
more devastating because it was this was
a complete shutdown for now over one
month of everything and on the numbers
this is much more consequential for the
economy than 9/11 thank you guys
[Music]